okay so this talk is on shrinkage of
decision lists and dnf
formulas
so i'm going to start by reviewing the
models of computation that i'll be
discussing
so first are dnf formulas so dnf
is a disjunction of clauses so
c1 to cm so each ci is a conjunctive
clause also known as a term
for example x2 and not x3 and xx
a decision list is a sequence
of m clauses and m output values so
such that the disjunction of the clauses
is a dnf tautology so it is true
on every input x in other words for
every every x satisfies at least one of
these clauses
and the output values b1 to bm can be
anything they don't have
to be boolean values necessarily
so the function computed by a decision
list
is is as follows so on an input x
the output is b i where i is the first
index of which the clause ci is
satisfied
i'll also be discussing decision lists
and demorgan formulas i assume
everyone's familiar here's some pictures
good so um associated with these models
of computation we have the following
complexity measures
so let f be any function on the
hypercube
again not necessarily boolean valued we
can define its decision tree
size and its decision list size denoted
dt of f
and dl of f where we measure size of
decision tree
by the number of leaves so the number of
output nodes
and decision list size by the number of
clauses
i didn't mention before but so without
loss of generality you can always take
the final clause and the decision list
to be the empty clause
but we still count that toward size
for boolean valued functions f we
additionally define the
minimum number of clauses in the dnf
formula that computes f
and l l of f denotes the de morgan
leaf size of that and
so these various complexity measures
also have
a width or depth version
and they satisfy
these kind of inequalities in particular
note that
under our way of defining things
decision list always has
at least one clause in it and and the
decision list
size is is that most decision tree size
in particular
every decision tree can be converted to
a decision list with this
with the same size
okay and yeah and you can think of you
can think of these as sort of um
[Music]
uh you know dnfs and cnfs are also
special cases of decision lists
and these are all you could think of
this as a version of
depth to unbounded fan and formulas
in some sense all right so the p
random restriction so a restriction is a
partial assignment of the variables of a
boolean function to
value 0 1 and
star denotes that a variable is left
undetermined
so um for a parameter p and 0
1 we denote by r sub p the p
random restriction which fixes each
variable to zero or one with equal
probability so probability one minus p
over two each
and leaves the variable unrestricted
with probability p independently
and for any function f we denote by
you know this f harpoon rp the
restricted boolean function on the sub
cube associated with the restriction
okay so it's very uh well well
established that
the p random restrictions simplifies
these very small comp like low
complexity measures like demorgan
formula size
and dnf cnf formula size so in the case
of demorgan formulas
over a long line of work we you know now
know tight bounds on the so-called
shrinkage of demorgan formulas
so you look at the expected leaf size of
a formula of a of a boolean function f
under rp
and this shrinks like p squared times
the formula size of f
and when p is very small
you know it shrinks like p times square
root
of the leaf size of f okay and i mean to
show a shrinkage of
p times l of f is trivial so this this
p squared says you you know you're
shrinking faster than
than than than you know what you'd
expect just looking at each leaf
another example of how rp simplifies
formulas is the switching lemma
so this is more than just shrinkage in
in expectation this gives a tail bound
but it's not in terms of size rather
it's it's uh at least the original
version of the switching limits in terms
of width
so if you know if i have a small
width dnf formula
and i hit it with a random restriction
first
sufficiently small p then i look at the
resulting c
and f width and you get an exponential
tail bound on that quantity
okay
that slide's repeated good so um
right so here's uh the results of this
paper so first of all
uh i first state a sort of
what i believe is a focal result
although i haven't found a reference
is a very simple proof that the decision
tree size
of f under p random restriction in
expectation
um is at most the decision tree size of
f
raised to the power log 2 of 1 plus
p and this bound is actually tight
um in in
in certain cases i believe an f is a
parity function this is actually
completely tight so our main result is
stated below
it's a similar looking upper bound on
the
expected shrinkage of decision lists
okay so instead of this log to one plus
p in the exponent we get slightly
slightly larger function of p
so log base 2 over 1 minus p of 1 plus p
over 1 minus p
and we so we get this for decision list
so saying that
the shrinkage of decision lists looks
like decision trees even the decision
lists are a more powerful model
and we get but the same proof gives the
same bound
if you replace decision list size by
dnf size plus one or c and f size plus
one
and we get the same bound okay and so
this
this exponent as a function of p this is
plotted above
and the thing to note here is that when
p
equal so this is a increasing function
it's zero and p is zero it's one when p
is one
um and in particular you know when p is
less than one
we get a bound which is non-trivial
um right so
making this uh more quantitative so if f
is a function any function with decision
list size
m then um we get the following bounds on
the decision list size
of f under p random restriction under
for for various settings of p
so when p is very small so when it's
order of
one over log m okay then we get a bound
of
two all right and if you want but
but even taking p just to be a constant
so if p in particular is
root five minus two then our our theorem
implies uh that the
the uh decisionless size and expectation
is like a like square root of m
um and then you know if you wanted to
shrink down to half the size then
you can take p actually very close to 1.
okay so a remark here is that the
switching lemma
um actually implies something
stronger than this when p is very small
so when p
is order of one over log m then the
switching lemma
you can use the switching limit to show
that the expected decision
tree size is at most two okay since
decision tree size is larger than
decision list size
this is an even stronger result however
the switching lemma um at least the
hostage version of the switching lemma
doesn't imply anything at all in the
you know when p is larger than one over
log n so in particular
it doesn't imply anything in the regime
where p is constant or where p
is close to one and this is known as the
so-called mild random restriction regime
and it
it's important in applications to
d randomization um and
uh and boolean analysis so
yeah so we expect our result might have
some some applications since
you know in particular uh for
for large values of p
good so um to give some perspective on
the result
i think it's useful to draw this
distinction between size
measures and the corresponding width
depth uh
complexity measures so here i've stated
first on the top here i've stated uh
hastad's
switching lemma uh so okay earlier i
stated in terms of
cnf width to dnf width but a more
general version in terms of decision
lists and decision trees is
the following bound it doesn't really
matter what it's saying just
we get some bound on the on the tailbone
on the
decision tree depth of the restricted
function
in terms of the decision list width
of the original function so in a paper
a few years ago there was a precursor to
this to this
current paper i proved a
version of the switching lemma in which
decision list width is replaced by
log of decision list size and i didn't
mention before but
the for each of these size measures for
decision trees
uh decision lists even demorgan formulas
the corresponding width or depth measure
usually bears some logarithmic
relationship
here so um
right and okay so
another result on which this this
current paper builds is uh from a recent
paper of love it wu and zang
where they prove uh shrinkage-like
result
for decision lists well in terms of the
decision list
width of f so their result set states
that
the expected decision list size
of f under a p random restriction is
bounded by four over one minus p
raised to the decision list width okay
and so here
i've just rewritten our result putting
the
putting the decision list size and the
exponent this is the same bound as in
our
main main theorem stated here
[Music]
anyway so the the point is here we're
doing something
you know our our result stands in
relation to loveit wu zang's result in
similar way that that that our switching
lemma relates to hostile switching level
that is
we replace decision list width with
log of decision list size
okay so let me say
something very briefly i mentioned that
this bound for
on the shrinkage of this decision tree
size
is a very yeah this is a very very
simple uh inductive argument
i mean this this is the entire proof
right here i'm not going to go through
it but it's based on
convexity it uses jensen's inequality
and yeah we we also use some
jensen's inequality something like in
like uh
like an entropy type inequality
so um i'm not going to say i'm not going
to
really say anything much about the
proof of our shrinkage bound for
decision lists rather i'm going to
prove for you a related bound that
contains the
the all the essential ideas
okay so and one key definition is the
index function associated with the
decision list
so okay let l be any decision list of
size
m and recall this means that
that the disjunction of c clauses c1 to
cm
is a dnf tautology b1 to bm are
arbitrary output values
so i'll denote by index sub l the
function which
maps uh you know an input in the
hypercube
to the first index in the index of the
first satisfied clause
right and so in other words the function
computed by l
l of x is just equal to the output value
b at the you know index l of x
okay and one observation is that without
loss of generality
you know the you can we can assume that
the index function is
subjective is on to uh otherwise if it
wasn't then
you could simply just delete from l any
pair c
i b i um where i is not in the image of
the index function
and in doing so you you you
will still you'll still have a dnf
tautology and you'll be computing the
same function
and then the way that uh the expected
decision list size
under p random restriction the way that
that's bounded in this paper of love at
wu and zang
and also in our paper uh is just by
using this observation from which it
follows that for any restriction row
the decisionless size of of
l under the restriction rho is
at most the size of the image of the
index function of l under rho okay
so
uh so the way that uh
yeah i'm not going to say anything about
the proof of our bound on
shrinkage but let me instead show you
something related that's simple and i
can fit the
the proof in one slide essentially so we
continue to fix a decision list l and
we're going to consider the following a
probability distribution
simply the mu
uh i guess i guess we could have i could
have simply written this as mu
i is just the probability so this here
is just the probability that
in that index l
of x equals i all right
um and note that um
that this this value mui well of course
this is a distribution that sums to one
and each mu i is at most uh two to the
minus
the the the width of of uh
ci the size of ci so the number of
literals in this clause
um so okay so what i'll
what i'll show you now is a simple
calculation that shows that
the average sensitivity of the function
computed by
l is at most twice the entropy
of this distribution mu which is the
most
uh twice log m okay
and this calculation is going to be
similar to our shrinkage bound
in some ways all right and i mean here
it is all on one slide
i'll just go through it very quickly so
the this first line here is just the
definition of average sensitivity
this is the expected number of
coordinates j and
one to n such that uh you know
flipping the the jth coordinate of the
input changes the value of the function
computed by l
so then the next line is just uh just by
linearity of expectations
in fact i guess this should even be
equality
um
yeah and and um right so
and note that okay so if l if
l of x is different from l of x with its
j coordinate flipped this means that the
associated index the
the index function is also different on
x and and
x with its j-th coordinate flipped okay
and in particular this means that you
know one is less than the other
and so you can easily show that that
this is okay i guess the inequality
belongs here this is almost twice
the uh i
i this is missing a summation here so
we'll also sum over
high equals 1 to m
right so this this event breaks up into
the to the probability
uh summed over um over
clauses i and variables j
the probability that the that that index
l of x equals i
and index l of x flipping its jth
coordinate
is bigger than i okay so we
we we just we pull out we
you know we break split up this
probability into the probability that
index
l x equals i which is just mu i
and then we have this conditional
probability over here
and then the the observation is that
this
conditional probability here is zero
when whenever you know whenever
i is not you know a variable occurring
in the clause cj
and obviously this probability is at
most one otherwise
but then summing over all um
summing overall
um
[Music]
summing over all um
[Music]
variables uh
the the the contribution that we get
from here
is at most just the number of variables
in ci and then we use our
you know earlier we noted that mu of i
is at most 2 to the minus
size of ci so that that gives this bound
here
and now we have just the expression
expression for the entropy of mu
so this equals twice the entropy of mu
and since mu is a distribution
uh with support size m this is
uh at most twice uh log n
okay so that's that's this simple proof
and all i'll say about the proof of our
shrinkage bound is that we
look at we define a different
distribution
okay something similar to mu i but it
instead of being generated by
x it's generated by p random
restrictions and it's a little bit
subtle actually how you define it but
but the essence of the proof is already
in this calculation that we saw here
um good so to wrap up the
yeah here i've just stated our bound
again our shrinkage bound for decision
lists
um so one open question you can ask what
is the
best constant okay c sub decision list
for which uh for which the shrinkage
the expected the decision the size of f
under rp is
order of decisionless size of f raised
to the
to the power uh c dl times p
and in the paper we show well so so
okay so our main result gives the upper
bound this constant is at most
uh 2 over natural log of 2. and
we can also show it's lower bounded by
the corresponding
constant for decision tree size which is
exactly equal to 1 over
natural log of 2. in some sense i
this constant here is
really should be thought of as the the
shrinkage exponent
in in the setting of decision list size
um another further question raised by
our work is what is the shrinkage of
depth
two ac zero formulas and our results for
c and f's and d and f settles the case d
equals two and we conjecture that for
any constant d that the bound on the
expected uh
formula you know depth t formula size of
f under rp
should be at most the depth the formula
size of f
raised to the order of p uh
p to the one over d minus one okay
and so this is what we prove in the case
d equals two
this is just order p and this is what
you would predict based on
based on the formula size of parity
under the hypothesis that parity is the
most shrinkage resistant
you know formula of a given size
okay so thank you